[Musique]
donc quand tout a commencé comme ça,
j'étais évidemment super nerveux à propos
de ce qui se passait et de ce que nous
aurions si vous obteniez un
diplôme ou si nous pouvions voir nos
amis avant  l'année scolaire s'est terminée, mais
je m'attendais en quelque sorte à une remise
de diplôme virtuelle ou peut-être pas du tout, mais
pour qu'ils aiment assembler tout cela
et pouvoir monter jusqu'à grand-mère
et prendre des photos et aussi juste voir des gens
comme passer je  Je pensais que c'était tellement cool que je me
sens très chanceux que cela signifiait beaucoup c'était
bien que nous n'en ayons pas un virtuel
et c'était en personne que je pouvais voir tous
comme mes professeurs et mon directeur et ensuite
recevoir mon diplôme en personne nos enfants
méritent quelque chose  spécial et nous ne
voulions pas avoir juste une remise des diplômes virtuelle
ou nous ne voulions pas faire juste un
drive-in nous voulons faire quelque chose de
spécial et c'est vraiment symbolique de
la vallée du mont Washington
[Musique]